[inaudible]
joining me today is an Iraq war veteran,
a political analysts at America's
favorite Black Gay Republican.
Rob Smith. Welcome to the Rubin
report. Thanks for having me.
Day America's favorite
Black Gay Republican.
That's a lot of pressure to
put in a Twitter bio. You know,
it's a lot of pressure. I feel that, um,
about a year ago about this time,
because I came out as conservative a
year ago and I out as conservative about
fascinating phrase that we're going to
talk a little, get into that. Absolutely.
But when I came out I said
I want something pithy and
catchy and kind of funny
because it's a joke. Yeah. America's
favorite Black Gay Republican.
I want there to be as sense of humor
in it because as you know, you know,
you use humor to bring people in,
then you hit them with the facts.
So a lot of people are going to be
going, wait a minute, wait a minute.
These guys are supposed
to hate identity politics.
But he's saying he's America's
favorite Black Gay Republican. Well,
here's my thing with that. I
think that there's a, number one,
all politics is identity politics.
So everybody does identity politics.
The left does it in the right,
does it,
I think that since coming
out as a conservative,
the way I play identity politics
is this, I'm black, I'm gay,
I'm going to rock war veteran,
I'm all these different things and they
don't matter about my politics because I
can be all of these things
and still love America.
And the way the left plays
identity politics is we hate you,
evil white men or you know,
this is my 72 genders or all this stuff.
So I feel like they use identity
politics not only in a super negative and
controlling way, but as a way to
get people's votes. 80 sucks though,
to kind of have to do a little bit of
what they do to throw it in their face.
Right. Cause like anytime, I don't
mention that I'm gay that often,
but anytime that I do,
I have no problem mentioning it.
Like I'm more than happy to talk
about it. Yeah. But anytime that I do,
it really only is to throw the use
the way that they use gay people.
Uh, it's to throw that back
in their face like I have no,
I don't want special credit for
it. You know? I mean, there's,
there's no special credit.
I think that for me,
when you get into my history and you know,
I'm going to Iraq war veteran,
I protested against,
don't ask, don't tell.
And I came out at 19 or I came out at 19
kind of like to myself and a couple of
friends of my mother. But when
I got out of the military, I'd,
we're on 21 years old because I had
to serve under, don't ask, don't tell.
I said I'm done with closets,
so I'm going to be out as gay.
So being gay to me has always
kinda been a political act.
And when I was protesting
against, don't ask, don't tell,
and getting arrested at the White House
and doing all these different things,
it was always a political
act for me to be gay.
So even coming out as a
conservative and being on the right,
and I'm proudly on the right,
being gay is still a political act
because I have to go into these spaces and
say I'm gay and this is why that matters
and this is how we can change the party
and change the idea of conservatism
to bring more people in.
Do you ever find that conservatives
have problems? We gave people,
cause people keep telling me that all
these conservatives hate gay people and I
go to events all
over the place, all over the
country, all over the world.
And I meet all these conservatives.
And I'm not saying there are none.
I have no doubt there's a certain sect
of Bible thumpers obviously that's still
do or some people that have different
religious beliefs. You know,
Ben Shapiro from an Orthodox
Jewish perspective, not
thrilled with gay marriage,
but now takes a libertarian approach
to civil marriage. I'm okay with,
I don't need him to bow to my beliefs,
but I don't find that there's any
real push back against gay people from
conservatives anymore. I just
don't see it. This is, yeah.
What I've seen and I've seen very,
very little in the way of people having
some problem with me being gay. The um,
in my experience, and I've been, God, I,
I spoke to the Metropolitan Republican
Club in New York City and I speak at
these republican events all over the
country and it's not so much I have a
problem with you being gay.
It's some people say, um, one,
one person came up to me and she said,
you know,
you're so good looking and you're black
and you know, you're all these things.
Like why do you have to talk about the
gay thing? And I told her, I was like,
I talk about the gay thing because it's
very important for me to talk about it
because people need to know there are gay
conservatives out there that follow me
right now that are afraid to come out.
And so I need to take this gain as to the
space and let them know that it's okay.
And also let you guys know that you're
missing out on a base of millions of
voters by, by doing things that
can even be construed as it. Yeah.
Do you think it's one of those things
where it's sort of you have to do it so
that it can get to the point that you
don't have to do it? Is that really? Yes.
Yeah.
And I was having the, um,
this conversation with,
with Candace and I shared this at the
blocks are rally over the weekend as well.
Um,
doing identity politics,
you do it now so that at a certain
point we don't have to do it anymore.
So we have to say that I'm
a gay republican or I'm a
black republican or I'm a
gay, black, conservative,
whatever you want to say.
Because as Americans we have to break
all that stuff down and figure out what
our identity as Americans is.
And that's the point for me.
Yeah.
All right.
So I want to talk about what it's
like coming out as a conservative,
as a gay black man. The rest
of it. But let, let's just
back up. Yeah. All together.
Tell me a little bit about growing
up in a family, that kind of thing.
So I am from Akron, Ohio.
One of the biggest, um,
things that people like
to say to discredit black
conservatives is that we were
all born wealthy. We were all
born upper, upper middle class.
And what we're doing is we're just
trying to protect our privilege.
I'm from Akron, Ohio. You weren't in Bel
Air. I was not in Bel Air. All right.
I was in Akron, Ohio in check
the stats on Akron, Ohio.
Anybody that doesn't know where that is,
um,
went to the worst one of the worst
public school systems in the state.
You can look on the website right now.
I can, public schools are rated d plus.
So I came from a single
mother household. You know, I,
I came from all this stuff and my
mother tells me this story now.
I was too young to remember,
but obviously I went to kindergarten in
a school that was in my neighborhood and
my mother tells me the story about
going to see me in kindergarten one day.
And it was just, you
know, 90% black school.
She's just to the people who are just
running around crazy. And she said,
I had to pull you out of that school
because I knew you weren't going to learn
anything, send me to school all the
way across town. Um, the school was,
was mostly white that doesn't
make it better or made it better,
was the property taxes and it was just a,
a more funded school.
So I was able to get that kind of base,
went back to my side of town for
middle school and high school,
which was just a terrible experience.
I,
and I tell people all the time
when they asked me about, you know,
sort of things in the world, in Western
civilization, all that, I'm like, look,
I went to Akron public schools. There are
so many things that I just do not know.
Um, and so I had that
experience. But in those days,
and probably still today,
somebody that looks like me,
that comes from where I come from,
if I'm not dribbling a basketball
or doing whatever they like,
they don't know what to do with you.
So it's not tracked in the college.
I wasn't attracted to any of these things.
I graduated high school at barely,
I think it was either 16 or
barely 17 and just had no path.
So I joined the military right out of
high school because I needed a path.
I needed a job. I needed something
to do. I wish that I could say in,
in my military service is
great and I love this country.
And that five years that I spent in the
military is probably the the greatest
thing I'll ever do. But I can't
lie and say that as 17 years old,
like I was so patriotic,
I wanted to serve my country like that.
And it was a way for me to move beyond.
Yeah. Yeah. All right.
Well before we get to that,
I can't let anyone mention basketball.
I got a boy. You got any skills?
And I don't, I'm the word black man
ever. I like am terrible at basketball.
I don't want to Brag,
but I won most improved player of the
New York City gay men's basketball this
year.
I think 2012 when I was already like 37
which could be most improved player at
37. That's not bad. That's
pretty good. It's really good.
Funny that um, they have that
gay basketball league there.
There's a part of me that
has always wanted to try it,
but I know it'd be so great,
bad and there were guys dunking.
I mean it's a serious,
it's a serious you got, it's funny because
I don't mind, I always, for me at least,
and I wonder for you,
like my sports and my sexuality had
nothing to do with each other ever.
Like I never brought my sexuality
when I'm out on the court in any way.
You know what I mean?
Like it wasn't like that.
The only reason I joined that league
was at that point in my life when I came
out late and I finally was like, Oh, let
me just meet some, I didn't really like,
like the bar scene or like, yeah, like I
didn't, I didn't like that and I was like,
Oh mate, if there's happened to be some
gay people that also like basketball,
maybe I'll find some friends. And I did
find some friends there and it's like,
and half of them, it's
like you're gay. Really?
Like when a guy like dunks on you and
like some of those guys like almost went
pro.
That's how good they got.
The weird thing about kind of like
being gay in not only am I gay,
I was so used to be a fat kid. Um, as
well. So you're really going forward here.
I'm like, I got everything. Did
you have Olympic at any point?
Did not have a was five.
Like I said,
I was like some fat black gay
kids was not athletic at, so I
didn't discover because there
are some sports I'm good at.
I played in the Gay Volleyball League in
New York City for a couple of years and
now I'm a pariah since I came
out as conservatives. Oh, GPA.
I thought they were all telling Shannon,
right? New York City gays, they're not,
are not intolerant. This is
not so much. I am shocked,
but I discovered that I am athletic
and I discovered that I'm great at
volleyball, great at tennis, you
know like like lifting weights,
like being in shape. But that's kind
of what I discovered about myself.
Kind of like,
I don't want to say later in life,
but definitely post 30 that I actually,
you know, have some sports skills.
Yeah. All right, good. So
when you joined the military,
where you were you already
sort of out to yourself?
Now I'm talking about
sexuality and politics,
politics, NYSE, but certainly
not a conservative thing. I was,
I was out to myself I think in the way
that a lot of gay teams are. You know,
I knew that I was kind of like feeling
away about guys that I was supposed to
feel about girls,
but I don't know if I could really
kind of quantify it in that way. Um,
and when I went into the military,
they actually,
in those days I actually asked you,
are you gay? And I said, no, I'm not.
Only because I, I didn't know
how to define it at the time,
but also I knew that that was a barrier
to, to what I wanted to do, you know.
So being in the military,
I came out to myself, you know,
started exploring my sexuality,
exploring all of that stuff. And like I
said, when I got done with the military,
coming out was like a political
act. I was like, no more closets.
Were you finding other gay people
in the military? Like what is that?
What was that like then? I mean, now,
now where it's more accepted and donate
that it doesn't exist or whatever
about,
um,
it's really funny how it is now is that
there are entire Instagram accounts
dedicated to gay guys in the military.
It's called gay military dudes.
And I love the fact that these bees,
young gay men in the military,
so open about, you know,
their sexuality and their posting thought
picks and they're doing all this like
great.
Yeah.
Yeah. And you're saying the military
hasn't crumbled since and it's causing
demoralization or everyone's still okay.
We still, everybody still good.
Okay. But back then there was this,
this underground movement of,
of gay people,
gays and lesbians that
were in the military.
And I remember the very first
pride I went to, I was, I'm,
I was stationed in Fort Carson, Colorado,
so like right on Colorado Springs.
And my very first pride was
Denver pride. So I went there, uh,
I think it was like maybe
19 or 20 at the time.
And that was my first time being around
a lots of other gay men at the same time.
And it was the first time
that, um, you know, I was,
I was getting attention from men and
then like people were looking at me and I
was like, oh, he's cute. And I was like,
oh, so this is what this is like. Um,
so there was a thriving underground
gay culture in the military.
Were you afraid to go out and go to a
gay pride parade while you're at serving?
Absolutely,
because it's like if don't ask, don't
tell was tricky because it was not only,
you can't tell somebody that you're gay,
but if you were discovered be gay,
then people would, um, you know, go up
the chain of command and kick you out.
But the thing about it is,
and this is what we always realize,
that nobody would care because there
are plenty of guys in my unit that,
that knew I was gay and a funny story,
there was a club called,
I think it's now different called hide
and seek in Colorado Springs and they
used to be open to people under
21 after 2:00 AM. So I would be,
yeah, yeah, yeah. It
will be open at 21. Uh,
it would be open to people under 21 after
2:00 AM because it'd be like open till
five and um, they wouldn't be serving any
booze. So I was young in the military.
I was like maybe 20 years old.
I would take a nap at 10 30 at night.
I wake up at one 30,
I would put on,
I had like black leather pants and
a tank top is insane, crazy. Um,
and then drive to hide and seek and
dance all night. And it was kind of,
it was a more gay crowd,
but it was mixed as well.
And I saw a couple of my sergeants there.
Wow.
The time at the club and they saw me,
they saw me and they saw me and they
were like, okay, this is interesting.
And they saw me kind of like dancing
with some red head and, you know,
feeling my oats, you know
what I mean? Feeling myself.
But I remember being terrified that
weekend that they were going to out me,
that they were gonna like tell my
superiors or whatever. It never did well,
but you had it on them too, right? I
mean, no, they weren't gay. They were,
they were just like,
they with their growth
friends because it was like,
oh wow.
I just had a completely different story
going on in my head for the last 30
seconds. Yeah, no, they were
there with their girlfriends,
their hour spot. Oh, whoa.
Yeah, yeah. Okay. Okay.
And so they did. They did
bust me out in a lot of these guys
are still my friends to this day,
my Facebook friends and they see
all the stuff that they're doing.
I'm here there and coming
out as a Republican.
I'm doing all this and they're
like, Smith, you know, we
always knew you were gay.
We just didn't care.
Yeah.
Cause you're a good soldier.
So I know what most gay people
feel about being in the closet.
Just how you can be as a person.
It's just, you know, you're, you're,
I always felt like I was like lying
all the time accidentally. Like I was,
it wasn't even intentionalized people
would ask me something and I could
immediately, you know,
where were you last night?
And I could just lie without
thinking, you know, it's really,
it's a really twisted, dark. It's not fun
to think back on that kind of thing. Um,
but for someone in the military
during don't ask, don't tell.
Do you think that affected
your ability to function as a,
as a soldier? And I think it did. Yeah.
Says the,
I think that to me the biggest thing
about being closeted in the military was
that it affected the relationships
that I was able to have with my fellow
soldiers.
There was a wall there and if I was
able to just be gay and nobody cared,
that wall wouldn't be there.
And,
and it's so important when you're serving
with people to be able to be close to
them. Like literally to be able to,
to bring your full self to work.
Because not only were we serving together,
I mean we deployed together, you know,
I did a tour in Kuwait,
I did a tour in a ripe,
these are the people that you're with.
These are basically your family and you
have to hide a part of yourself and all
the, that they were hanging out or doing
things that we could become closer.
I was separating myself from that because
I knew that there was a part of me
that had to hide.
And so when I bring all
of that stuff now too,
to being gay and being open as
a conservative and everything,
it is so important for me to be open in
that way because there I can't have that
wall there between me and
other conservatives and
me and other people in the
movement. And the younger
conservatives have been s like,
these kids don't care.
They don't care.
Some of the older ones need to kind of
be brought around a little bit, but man,
they don't care.
Do you think it's just because young
people somehow have started to embrace a
more libertarian view of
the world? I mean, it's like
we've got sort of, you know,
crazy leftism. On one hand you seems
to be catching fire all the time.
It's really pushed on us by the media.
But then I see,
and I guess it's a little selected by,
by who invites me to these schools,
but I see such a strong libertarian
like spirit with these kids.
Not meaning that they're all
politically libertarians at every level,
but like they just,
they want to live their lives.
They want to love who they love,
they want to smoke whatever they
want to smoke or whatever. And,
and I'm very enthused by that. I think
that the, the generation right now,
they really do just,
they just want to let people live and
they want to let people do their thing.
They don't care about gay,
they don't care about transgender,
they don't care about any
of these different things.
They just want to let people live.
And it's really funny,
like the conversation I had last
night, I'm at Ucla, I had an event.
And it's so funny because when I was
protesting against don't ask, don't tell,
I was, I was, you know,
doing a lot of lecture work and I was
talking with the young LGBT student groups
and I was just like, you know, you
can be anything you want to be.
Let's empower you. Like,
let's do all this stuff.
And I'm having these same conversations
with young people who are afraid to come
out as conservative. Same thing.
Date. Yeah, no, it is. All right.
So let's just dive into that then too,
because I really do feel
this now because I find,
I know what the closeted thing was
like, as, as in terms of sexuality,
but I see this now the amount of emails
that I get and when I meet people on the
street and they'll kinda whisper
it to me, you know, it's not even,
they're not even saying, yeah, well
they'll go hit Dave and then they'll go,
it's not even like they're saying
they are conservative per se.
They're basically just saying they're
not a progressive yeah. That they're not,
they don't come from the woke monster.
You know what I mean?
And I,
and they're walking around with that,
that feeling that you described a moment
ago related to sexuality where you
can't be fully there with someone.
And I think there are,
there are quite literally,
I think there were millions of people
in the United States that are walking
around in a closeted stand,
not because they're Nazis are white
supremacists are haters are racist,
but just because they happen to have
either some conservative beliefs or uh,
some libertarian beliefs
or something like that.
And I see it all the time and I'm
sure you probably get 10 times as many
messages as I do, but you see it and
when you go have these conversations,
it is the same conversations that I was
having with a young gay kids that were
afraid to come out. I had a
conversation with the kid last night.
He was just like,
man,
how do I come out to my friends is
conservative or how do I come out to my
friends as somebody
who's like not a leftist?
And this is what I always say to them.
You know,
the real ones will stick around the
fake ones. We'll go, I promise you that.
And when, like a year
ago, I remember sitting,
I was visiting my best friend in
Vegas and I was thinking about,
I know from my experience, you know,
being very prominent in, in the don't ask,
don't tell thing that when
you come out as something,
like you're coming out to make a statement
and it has to be a media moment and
you have to get your face out there
because that's what gives other people the
strength to come out. And I was
like, man, if I don't do this,
somebody else is going to do this
because I know I'm not the only black gay
republican out there.
I have fans that are,
that are Black Gay Republicans and Latina
Lesbian Conservatives and all sorts of
stuff. Um, but I was
like, if I don't do this,
somebody else is gonna do this and
somebody needs to do this because these
people need to know that it's okay.
And when I take the hits and you take
the hits and Candice takes the hits and
all of these other people takes the hits,
it makes it easier for these
other people to come out.
So I've asked a lot of my guests that have
taken those heads. Yeah. This question,
I usually ask it at the end,
but what do you think it is
about you that allows you to,
to want to take the hit
or maybe not even want to,
that you do whether you want to or not.
I'm telling you the army built
something that is indestructible,
indestructible.
I served for five years.
I saw some things on a rock.
I saw some things overseas and
in not even outside of that.
What the basic training does is it just
builds you up and as somebody that has a
lot of discipline that can take a lot of
hits and I know enough about media and
I know enough about the people that
are making the moves right now.
I know that it is important for me to
do this because, and I'm telling you,
they have,
and you've probably seen the shift in
the past five to seven years since you've
been doing this and have really
been blown up and traveling all the,
all the world.
There's a shift that's going
on and I believe it's real.
And in three to five years,
me being a black gay conservative,
this is going to be
like, you know, whatever.
And I hate the fact that
the gay community, I'm,
I'm Kinda my am ex communicated now, you
know, so I'm not getting invites to the
thrilled with me there. Yeah,
we should start our own awards.
We totally should do the, the,
the gate free thinkers. Right.
You know,
but you get excommunicated and they're,
they're very high level people that,
I mean I used to get invited to,
to all this stuff in New York City
because I was a gay person in the media.
And when I came out last year it was like,
it was like silent.
So what does that really tell
you about these organizations?
And sorta like glad and these other
organizations that they're there for gay
people,
they're supposed to be for gay people and,
and if they subscribe to
intersectionality, they should be
for black people.
And the rest of it.
But you're saying you were in that they
loved you. You come out as conservative.
We're done with you would,
it tells me is number one,
that these organizations are not
for all Lgbtq people. Therefore,
Lgbtq, um, democrats, first of all,
these are leftist organization.
People really need to understand this.
I know I say it all the time,
but like I think that because people
just think glad is for gay people.
This is for this per, and it's like, no,
that's not really what's going on here.
But it really takes work to get people
to fully understand why that is true.
And there used to be, and we talked about
this a little bit before we started,
before we started filming,
there used to be a part of me that wanted
nothing more than to be kind of like a
gay celebrity in life. Oh, I get to go,
I get to go to the glad media awards and
I get to go to the HRC red carpets and
I get to,
to be,
and now I realize that what I'm doing
right now is so much bigger than any of
that stuff. And I'm not, I'm
doing this not for fame or,
because the concept of fame has been
very strange to me and in grappling with,
with this newfound attention.
But it's not about being with some delist.
I'm gay celebrities on the red carpet.
It's certainly not about being with,
even though I love the way,
usually the ones that they're
putting on the red carpet,
they're not even gay half the time.
Oh yeah.
I told you I used to do these red carpets
when I had a show on our Q and I was,
so I was interviewing people.
I was on the other side of the red carpet
and mostly it was just housewives of
New York drunk. These drunk
plastic women that are like, ah,
I'll have them gave,
let me tell you something and I can
tell you a story and she will remain
nameless. But I was actually at, Huh? Oh,
I can tell you the name
of it, so yeah. Yeah.
But I was on one of these award shows
and this was obviously before I came out
when I was still getting
invited and this person was H's,
a drunken sloppy mess.
And I'm just like,
how is this celebrating gay people?
How is this elevating us?
And so what you have is
with the glads of the world,
this is about bullying
Hollywood celebrities in the
thinking that you know what,
if you don't, if you don't show
up to our red carpet events,
you're not supporting, you know, the
Lgbtq community. So that's what, what,
what that's all about.
Um,
the HRC is obviously of leftist
organization like very much so I left this
organization and what irritates me
about this entire thing is that these
organizations were not started
as leftist organizations.
They weren't supposed to be left as well.
Cause at that time they
wanted real equality.
You didn't want it to
quality under the law.
They wanted the things
that we have right now.
But to continue to get funding,
to continue to be data centers
for the Democratic Party,
they have to go with
whatever far left craziness.
And it's the intersectionality cold.
And it's,
it's being lectured by a queer Muslim
at the glad media where it's about how
gays aren't inclusive enough for, for
Islam and, and about, you know, how you,
how the LGBT community needs to accept
undocumented people who are just like all
this stuff that was never,
it's never what our movement was about.
And at the same time for me as a gay man,
I know that um,
HIV aids rates among young black
gay men are still exploding. Um,
we have a huge problem with meth.
There's real stuff's still going on.
So what should they have done then?
Was there a moment that there
should've been a course correction?
So say gay marriage gets passed
on. Ask. Don't tell is yeah.
What do you think the organization's, if
they had done it right? I mean, is it,
is it, do they close up shop? Do
they well, that's what I think.
That's what they were afraid of.
They were afraid of.
Now that we have this quote unquote true
equality that the close up shop Chris,
Chris rock that had been
one of his great lines,
the cops need a certain
amount of crime. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think that would happen after,
don't ask,
don't tell repeal a marriage equality
were two of the biggest gay rights wins of
our generation. Like I think of our
lifetime. And after that happened,
I think that they just needed something
else. They needed some more funding,
they needed to,
to continue to be relevant.
So they'd gone into all of this
intersectionality far left insanity.
And what I see from being so open and
being a gay conservative out here is that
there is a large group of gays and
lesbians that are conservative that want
nothing to do with the leftist nonsense.
They don't want to vote with
their sexual orientation.
They want to vote for their values,
they want to vote with their pocket books.
You know, they, they, they want to vote
based on who they are. So you're saying,
let me get this straight.
Gay people are just like everybody else.
Just like everybody else stayed.
Just like everybody's getting just crazy,
right nuts in the same.
And you'd think so where are, where
are the, the right gay organizations.
Are there any,
I mean like the log cabin Republicans,
are there anybody that you're
out there and you're like, oh,
you guys are doing some good
grassroots related to the eye issues.
It's always,
it's never going to be the HRCS
and the glads of the world.
It's always the grassroots
organizations. It's your, your,
your um, Columbus pride. You know, it's,
you're the Brooklyn
Community Pride Center.
It's like these are the organizations
that are money really needs to go to
because these organizations are doing
work on the ground to like give young LGBT
people access to jobs and education and
all the stuff that the glads and the HRC
is of the world claim
that they're fighting for.
But really they're just paying
a lot of big wigs, sick,
like insane six figure salaries and,
and trying to get Madonna on a red carpet.
And God loved Madonna. We don't love
Madonna, but that's not the word.
So I always try to elevate the smaller
organizations because they need the time
and the money more than the big ones.
For the record,
I'm more of a Tina Turner guy.
You Remember Tina Turner?
I hear she gives an amazing show.
I haven't been yet. I've never,
well I don't think she's
going live anymore.
I think she's done tore
and I think she like,
she moved to like Sweden or something.
I think she gave up her us citizenship
and she's just riding it out and man. Ah,
but um, I, I would, I will say about
Madonna. The gays are going to kill me.
I saw her one time and it wasn't
great. I saw her once. New York, uh,
confessions, confessions on the dance
floor. It wasn't, it was Mbna oh,
that's the one. Yeah. That was
the whole dance album, right?
We know confessions was the dance out.
Okay.
So that day was like in 2012 I think
that was odd. Mtma when I went to the,
you went, that's okay. I paid a
lot of money for those tickets.
We were at Madison Square
Garden somewhere out in jars.
I was at Madison Square Garden,
I was way up there in the rafters
and I was just like, yeah, yeah,
I'll wait until I'll wait until they're
at the Farewell Vegas tour where she
finally does all the things
that people want to hear.
Right, right. Well, age wise,
she's, she's getting there. Yeah.
But you know, she keeps it together.
She keeps it together. She does.
She does. All right. Let's, uh,
let's talk a little bit about,
I've heard candidates talk about
how most black people actually are
conservatives,
but they sort of don't know it or they
can't accept it because of the way the
media has treated black people.
That the default position is you must
be a democrat. Yeah. Do you sense that,
I sensed that.
And to get into that,
you really have to understand how deeply
entrenched this idea that black people
have to be Democrats is. And,
and I said this a little bit, uh,
on the vice thing that I did,
we have black celebrities,
entertainers,
ball players,
athletes from the top of
the charts to the answer,
the thought with 10,000 followers.
These are all people that are
pushing leftists. You know,
they are pushing leftists
tactics and black people.
We more so than I think other races.
We look for representation in media
and we look for representation and pop
culture and these are our heroes. These
are the people that we want to be like.
And that's one of the reasons why this
idea that we have to be on the left is so
firmly entrenched. So why,
why do you think that is
looking for sort of elsewhere,
do you think that has something to do
with the black family and some of the
stuff that Larry elder would talk about?
It has everything to do with,
with Larry elders talking about
literally odor will tell you,
and I'm pretty sure he did that.
The number one kicked the shit out of me.
That's what woke me up.
Yeah.
But leary elder will tell you that the
number one problem in the black community
is black poppin listeners, right?
That we don't have men in the homes.
And so when there's not a man in the home,
when there's not a man to,
to raise that young man in the home,
they look to athletes, ball players,
the Collin, Kaepernick's, whoever.
And so when Colin Kaepernick,
just to give an example,
if some kids he wrote right and he sees
Colin Kaepernick taking a knee for black
lives matter,
and that's where he's getting his politics
from because that kid doesn't know
who I am.
They can certainly doesn't know who Larry
elder is and the fact that kid is not
gonna know who Larry elder is is a shame.
You know what I mean?
And so that's the message that we get.
Even though black people do tend to
be a little bit more conservative,
just in terms of if you,
for example,
said that black people need fathers in
the home and we need to stop having kids
out of wedlock and we need to start doing
all of these things that will elevate
ourselves. You're a racist. I would say.
I would say everyone, regardless of race,
should have those things to
the best of their ability.
Not to say it can't happen otherwise.
You just said you were
raised by your mother.
I want to do turned out pretty good.
[inaudible] those outlier cases. Yeah.
But at the same time I was,
I went to military for five years
and so the military taught me,
the military gave me a male influence.
Um, multiple male influences.
The military taught me how to be a man.
The military taught me discipline.
The military taught me courage and
military taught me self control.
The military taught me reliance,
all of the things that a father
is supposed to teach you.
And so now me as a,
as a gay black man saying these things,
you know, if you're a white
person, you know, you're
white supremacist or whatever.
But I'm sorry about that, you know? Yeah.
I'm, I'm the COO and I'm the uncle Tom,
I'm whatever.
And there is this very huge movement of
like very far left gay black men who it
seems like they have these large online
platforms and it seems like their entire
goal in life is to just tear down straight
black man or tear down the idea of
masculinity or tear down the idea that
our boys need men in the homes to teach
them how to be men.
So they want to tear that down.
And when I look at their platforms and
I look at the things that they say,
and sometimes they come after me and I
ignore it because none of those people
are my enemy.
There is nobody that is out there that's
a public figure that looks like me.
That is not my enemy, that is my,
these people are not my enemy.
But when I look at the
platform that they have, I say,
you have so many people listening to you.
Why are you always preaching
divisiveness and hatred?
Why are you trying to tear down black men?
We should be lifting each other up.
We should be empowering each other because
you know our community meets. Yeah.
Well, it seems to me that mostly, and
it's not just with say those black men,
but anyone that buys in
to the far left ideology,
they want conformity and they, there
is some sort of, as I say all the time,
Peter Boghossian,
he's been on the show many times,
calls this postmodern ideology a secular
religion and they don't want a pasta
date and they especially don't want
to pass states that look like you.
That's crazy. I've never, I've
never really heard that. I mean,
I've talked about that idea
and some of my lectures,
but I've never heard it say quite
like that because this is my thing.
And one of the best things that happened
for me over the past year is that I
found religion and I found
God because I will tell you,
and you probably know there and I don't
know, I don't know what your religion is,
but for me there's a lot of people
that are running after Twitter,
followers and fans and Instagram followers
and fame and money and all this other
stuff and not,
there's not an amount of Twitter followers
or fame or any of that stuff that is
going to fill that hole
that you're looking to fill.
And Twitter followers don't feel
the existential void things out.
What you telling me you do not the black
hole of existence you've got filled by
Instagram line is nodding. You've got
like 10 times my following. And when,
when things started taking off a
little bit last year, like when,
when my life started getting
bigger in some other ways,
I had to make things smaller. Um,
and so I made my circle smaller and,
and I tried to get close with
my husband and my best friends,
but I also found God. And it is when
you not religious before, were you not,
were you, were you specifically not a
believer before? No, not at, not at all.
I was raised in the church
African Methodist Episcopal.
Um, so the AME church,
like I was there. And when you're young
and black in the church churches a full,
like an all day event,
I'm there at 10:00 AM for Sunday school
and then you do the service and then
it's two 30 dinner. You're like, you're
not out of there until after dark.
But I think that in my first 11 years in
the city when I was kind of doing some
of the, don't ask them until
activism and trying to find my path,
I was looking for fulfillment in all
of those things that I told you before.
And when I started getting those things,
I realized that not that it wasn't enough,
but there needs to be
something else to ground me.
And one of the biggest things that the
super far left tells young gay people is
that God is your enemy and
Christians are your enemy.
And Evangelical Christians want to put
you in conversion campaign and just all
of this crazy stuff to separate them
from relation so that this far left
ideology becomes their religion.
And I say that,
you know,
God is a gift in my life right now.
And I say that and I'm not embarrassed
by that anymore and I don't feel like
that's something that I should be ashamed
to talk about. Even as a, as a gay man.
Somebody described me on, on Twitter
when I think it's funny and they said,
um,
former military leftist turn right
wing Bible thumping from tarred.
And I thought that, that a lot of
words, a lot of where it was hysterical.
I showed that to my husband.
We both cackled I don't
hear you Bible. Nothing. No,
I mean I'm not, you may, maybe a Trump
card and I, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right wing Trump tart. I
don't Bible thump. I just,
I talk that I talk about religion in my
life and how it's grounded me and how
it's become just a really powerful guiding
force and it is fulfilling and it is
grounding in a way that, let me tell
you something as a young gay man, like,
like all the sex, all the
partying, all that stuff,
like I did it all and there's,
there's nothing in that.
And for me it is becoming
grounded in religion and God.
Do you think a lot of gay people have
like an extra struggle when it comes to
sort of be questions?
Cause I know I definitely did like that.
You are something that society tells
you at least, you know, how old are you?
How old are you?
I am I allowed to ask how old you are.
I just get to the one
question that I get it.
I'm in my thirties you're in your
thirties wow. Wow. Yeah. All right.
So that's how it is. Well I as an elder,
I am 42 years. Okay. So, you know,
when I was in say high school and college,
you know, this way before gay marriage,
you know, during don't ask, don't tell,
and I never really saw sort
of a functional future. I,
it's not that I saw at dysfunctional
future, I just saw no future.
I was just like, I'm now and I'm
just going to keep living now.
So something like that.
Um,
but I do think for a lot of gay
people that causes like this weird
belief schism or something like that.
So it's interesting to hear that just in
the last year you've come back to some
of this stuff and I think a
lot of people have, by the way,
they are in, in, in I want them to,
and it's like, so we, we tell the,
I guess I don't,
I don't want to say right wingers anymore
because I guess I'm a right winger now,
but they always say that,
you know,
you can't call gay lifestyle because it's
my sexual orientation as a lifestyle.
But there are elements of it that
are very lifestyle oriented. The,
the party lifestyle, the circuit
party culture, the gay culture.
Like all of that other stuff. Um, I
don't like any of that stuff. Yeah.
I like the golden girls who
doesn't like the golden girls.
I love like gay enough for me.
You know what I mean?
I watched three hours of the golden girls
on a Sunday morning. I'm very happy.
But the cool thing right now is that
people like you and people like me can
reach these young people and they can
see something that is outside of all of
that messiness. And I come to it
is not somebody that judges it,
but if somebody that did it all now,
I never did drugs. That was never,
I was never a druggie.
I don't even like smoking weed.
They say that people that are better,
a little neurotic and
I'm a little neurotic.
They say we doesn't go well with
us and it doesn't go well with me,
so I never did the drugs.
Yeah.
Yeah. I haven't found the right
[inaudible] good, but I get it.
You're a conservative now.
Yeah. No, it's not even that because
some them, and it's really funny,
I'm like to the right of some
people in marijuana legalization,
but that's a whole nother issue.
We can go there, but yeah, good.
But I did all the partying.
I did all of the circuit parties and I
traveled and kissing boys and having lots
of sex.
It's like I did all that
and I fundamentally know
that there's nothing there.
And I think that the problem with
reaching these kids right now is that I am
like,
it feels lonely because it really does
feel like I'm one of maybe three or four
people that like have these large
platforms and obviously you as well,
but they see people that are like,
you know,
they see the drag queens and the Hollywood
celebrities and all that other stuff.
I just really want these kids to see
that they can have a more grounded life.
And not that I'm trying to be anybody's
role model in a way because I'm like,
my thing is I did all the mess.
So you don't have to.
Yeah, I feel very, even
though I didn't do the math,
I mean I did do my own mess in
a way. Yeah. Like, and I did,
I did do the drugs and I did do all that.
But I wasn't really into the scene,
let's say.
But I do feel that too.
I'm not trying to be anyone's role
model at all. 100% not failure.
Yeah. And I lived through, if anything,
I would say I lived through
shit to get to where I am.
So that hopefully the next that that
gay kid that's 18 doesn't have to do it.
You know what I mean? And yeah, we're
living right. Cause everyone's got shit.
We're on the right.
And the people that came before me
lived through far more than that.
So there's an interesting parallel here
with the way Hollywood treats all of
this. Because you mentioned something
about, or just a moment ago,
you mentioned how,
uh,
the black culture puts more emphasis
on Hollywood and these figures and
everything.
And I was thinking like,
even just in the Oscars last year that
Black Panther was nominated for an Oscar.
Now I've seen every,
so I think we're going to have a
little difference here because I,
I've seen every marvel movie I just saw
I end game a couple of days ago, uh,
as what's going to make me
go see it at this weekend.
I don't want to say anything right now,
but um,
but I've seen every one of the movies. I
love superhero movies. I Love Star Wars,
love all that stuff. Black Panther was
a very average movie there. There was,
in my opinion,
there was nothing racist.
Same for same racist.
Well guess what? Why are you all of you
said it too, but he's a self hating.
Black guys just can't win here button.
But my point is,
but it was within the
scheme of superhero movies,
none of them get nominated
for anything and that's fine.
But it was very average.
It in my opinion,
it was just a very average movie and it
got nominated for all these things and I
saw the media was like, ah, see
Black Panther. Got It. Like,
like it was some major wins that would
somehow make people more equal or feel
better. Or now we can look at the
numbers and go this many black films,
this and this many white is.
And I was like,
it just seems to me that the aim is just
so off of where you should go for the
price,
the real price.
No, and I agree with you on that personal,
I love Black Panther. I really do.
Like I'm a,
I'm a huge,
yeah, no, it's perfectly fine.
But you got an Oscar Award
winning nominated for that.
She make a really good point in minority
communities and specifically the two
groups that I'm a part of,
blacks and, and, and gay people.
We always look for representation in
the media as some sort of barometer of
progress. And that's a trap. It's a huge,
it's a big Tridell Chinese people do it.
Yeah.
Because they're focused on making money.
And when I tell him and I'm all about it,
and when I go give these lectures,
and I told people that the biggest way
for any group of people to achieve any
kind of power is financially.
It is not through Oscar nominations.
And that stuff is great and it's amazing,
but it's,
it's kind of like these,
these are false idols because Black
Panther is great for visual representation
and it's great that all
those people on the stage,
and I personally think this amazing movie,
but what that does for the young black
kid that's struggling in the high school
that I went to right now, not
much. Not much. Right. Um, and,
and we do it as gays and
lesbians as well. If, you know,
if somebody comes out and look
at the, look at the, the, the,
the Buddha judge thing
right now. Yeah. Um,
look at how people in this
is somebody that is, I mean,
I'm not a Buddhist meditator at all,
but I, it seems to me, you know, I,
I see the game,
I see what's going on and I see the way
that he picked the fight with pence to,
to ingratiate himself to the far left
though. Use it. Like, I get it, I see it.
But just the idea that any power
comes from media representation,
it's,
it's false hope.
It also separates the people
from what should be the end goal.
Because I think that empowerment for any
of our communities only comes through
entrepreneurship. Look at this, look at
that. That is your name. On that sign,
you are an entrepreneur.
And if somebody had given me the message
about entrepreneurship when I was 1718
1920 God knows where I'd be by now.
And one of the biggest things that
I've gotten out of out of become a
conservative and kind of moving
over to the right is the fact that
entrepreneurship and capitalism
is not a bad thing in my,
both of our communities need more of it,
but especially my black community,
we need more entrepreneurship.
We need more job creators.
We need to stop looking for
representation in the media to, to,
to elevate ourselves or to make
us feel good about ourselves.
So when you see then the Democrats, so
just in the last couple of weeks, yeah,
there's now this debate suddenly
about reparations and I,
I saw the video of Senator Elizabeth
Warren talking about reparations and she's
going to commission a panel about
reparations. And my first thought,
the first thing that just popped into
my head as I was watching it was,
holy shit,
Candice did it.
You know what I mean? Like
whatever anyone thinks it. Candace,
she created enough of a crack in that
layer that that caused black people to
either be completely afraid of saying
they're conservatives are just,
just say that they're not Democrats.
Yeah. That now the Democrats are like,
Oh shit, what do we got left?
Here's money. Could you take,
yeah, I bet some money in the
words of the Great Candice Owens,
fear in handouts is what they have
to offer black people this cycle,
and it is no mistake,
first of all,
that Donald Trump got more
African American votes in
the two previous Republican
nominees combined.
That is just the fact,
and it is no mistake that you know what?
You know people say a lot about the
black set movement and they say it's not
real.
It's not that.
And what I tell people is that you're
going to see Republicans make a bigger
play for the black vote than
you had ever seen before.
I think in the history of this country,
and it's not going to come
through fear and handouts,
it's gonna come from talking to the people
that are the real job creators in the
real entrepreneurs and saying that
these policies will help you create.
And the fact that reparations is even
a conversation right now among the
Democrats means that they're scared.
Um, I, I just did a video for,
for turning point about reparations and,
and not to spoil any of that,
but none other than Bayard Rustin who
is one of the architects of the march on
Washington,
a huge civil rights leader who by
the way was black and gay in the 60s.
They interviewed Baird Rustin about
reparations in 1969 and he said,
it's, he said, this idea is ridiculous.
And the quote is something like,
if my great, great grandfather, you know,
picked cotton than
reparations are owed to him,
but he's dead and nobody owes me anything.
Yeah.
But this is how they're going
to try to buy the black vote.
It's also just a crazy way of
dividing this. Yes. Each other.
I was at a cousin's wedding on my
husband's side this past weekend and uh,
was with the young guy who's 21,
22 and he was telling me about
how woke it is in college.
Now this is this a kid who grew up,
his mother died when he was very young.
He grew up, he had no money,
bunch of different homes, uh,
all sorts of crazy history in the family.
And it's like the idea that this kid has
privileged because he's white and we're
going to take from him. I mean that's in
essence, that's what he was saying like,
and it wasn't specifically
about reparations,
but just this idea that this kid is
somehow guilty or somehow privilege just
because of the skin color, having nothing
to do everything. He's lived through it.
But that's what they're pushing
on everybody. I mean, you know,
that's what they're pushing
and, and there's not a lot
of pushback to that idea.
And I just feel that there's a correction
going on right now and there's a
correction because you're seeing a lot
more conservatives that are younger and
browner and whatever. And there's a really
different movement right now. And the,
the, the leftist, it's like, I
call it the intersectionality Colt.
The intersectionality Colt will eat itself
because there's all these things that
you cannot stay on the left right now.
And there's somebody who,
I'm not going to name, but
this is, this person is,
it has a platform as a feminist, right?
And this is a male feminist. And I'm like,
great, you know, do what you gotta do,
but don't call me Trans phobic for
defending women's sports or women's spaces
or,
or lesbians who are now,
who now feel pressured into having
relationships with transgender women. Um,
when, when you call yourself a feminist
and you're not standing up for,
for lesbians. And I standing up for
women in that way, I, I, you know,
you call me whatever you want to call
me, but I'm, I'm always going to,
to stand up for, for lesbians to stand up
for women in that way. But like I said,
the intersectionality coat there,
things that they can't say, um,
they're things that they can't say
about radical Islam. You know when,
when they run into a gay bar and kill
49 of us, you mood, they can't say that.
You got Jonathan Capehart
running around talking about, oh,
this guy was a closeted gay in this.
I was this and this guy was that.
And I'm like,
that completely ridiculous and not true.
And we know that that's not true now,
but the intersectionality Colt will
eat itself because there there is,
it is becoming to the point where there
are too many things that they can't say.
So people like you and I have to
say the things that they can do.
Is that doubly tough then
for you as a gay black man?
Because the culture, if we're talking
about black culture and gay culture,
there's so much humor richness,
their political incorrect. Yes. Yeah.
All of these things.
So for someone like you to be fed these,
these ideas that you've
obviously rejected now,
but to be fed these ideas that would
stop you from joking the way you want to
joke or saying something politically
incorrect with the rest of it, it's like,
like I remember going when I would go to
gay bars and they would be like a drag
queen. Now I again, I was never into it.
I thought drag queens were all bad comics.
Like they all struck me as just
hack comics. That being said,
they would say a ton of
politically incorrect shit.
They would mock gay people.
They, I mean they would mock everybody.
That was the point where now it's like,
I don't know,
I don't know what's going on in the,
in the drag queen world these days,
but it's like,
I'm guessing it's gotten pretty bad
because they're probably really afraid to
say,
yeah,
I'd be irreverent. I mean, I, I think
that right now, I mean I, I'd love drag.
I ru Paul's drag race. I'm like,
I'm all about it. You know, my,
my husband and I are big fans.
When I voted for the, in the last
election I voted for Gary Johnson,
but I used to live in West Hollywood
so I had to go over there to, to vote.
I was standing behind
Ru Paul at the voters.
Oh, not in drag. And you
want to talk about like,
and you want to talk about how crazy
the is. Let's talk about Ru Paul.
Let's talk about the crazy blue Chez.
Ray's ease on the LGBT
left coming after Rupaul.
Like forgive me for being gay.
Mvaa you come from mother,
you say that Ru Paul is transphobic or
she doesn't represent gains and whatever.
What was it that she said this
about a year and a half ago,
this is about a year and a half ago.
Like ru Paul did an interview where
she says she doesn't, we're Paul. Hey,
because we pause,
man.
Rupaul said he doesn't believe in
transgender women in drag because drag is
supposed to be a male's elevated
and comedic idea of what a woman is.
And so they came after Ru Paul for
that. They came after. There was a,
I'm a segment on drag race called
a sheet shemale girl, you got shit.
You know what I mean?
And so they kept the blue checks
came after Rupaul for that.
And so it's really funny when I look at
the Ru Paul situation and we'll look at
somebody who has done more for,
for LGBT culture than maybe anybody
walking on this earth right now.
And the fact that people are attacking
him after everything that he's done tells
me that these people are insane,
tells me that there's not enough.
And if there's one
thing that I would need,
I don't know if this is a
critique because I, I love Rupaul.
And by all accounts I hear
people say that Rw is amazing.
It's that like real kind of bended bending
the knee a little bit. Oh, you know,
he apologized. We're bending
the knee a little bit. Um, um,
two people coming for him and I want to
get to a point where we are not bending
the knee to the mob anymore.
They came after Ellen degenerates what
lesbian on this planet has done more for
freaking gay and lesbian visibility.
And an Ellen degenerates came after Ellen
just because she sat down with Kevin
Hart and Hart for having the conversation
with Kevin Hart and they came for
Ellen.
And so this is what I say,
if they're coming for ru
Paul in Ellen degenerate,
they'll come for you and me so die.
So I will never been the knee. I was,
um,
we were supposed to have them an LGBT
conservative panel at the LGBT center in
New York City. Um, and when, you
know, people found out about it,
we've got excommunicated from the center
because we were all racist and all
white and transphobic and
all of that other stuff.
And so I will never apologize
for things that I say.
I don't try to offend people,
but you're certainly not going to control
my tongue and I'm not going to bend
the knee to these people.
And I'm really glad that Ellen didn't,
and I hope Rue Paul never
does again because these are
two people that have done
more for this community
that anybody in the planet,
certainly not some blue check mark that
writes for some blog. Right? Right.
But we create this reverse or this
perverse I should say incentive structure
where it's like there's a lot of
value for those blue checkers.
We go after them cause it's like,
oh you can ruined one of the heroes.
Even if they were the ones that
paved the road for you. Wow.
If you can build your castle
on their blood, you know,
car Cardi B says they do
anything for cloud cloud chasers.
That's all they're doing. And the
fundamental critique that I have with,
with a lot of these people that the
cloud chasers is that the platforms are
always built on destruction.
It's cancel culture.
So everything is always built on.
If I build a platform of let's say
like a one hundred thousand two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand and my
platform is completely built on tearing
people down,
like I'm going to go up to Dave Ruben
because he's got 10 times my following and
he said something I don't like,
so maybe I'll get some attention for,
for tearing him down. You
know what I mean? So if your
platform is built on that,
then you always have to look for new
things to be offended by new people to
destroy new cloud to chase.
And I don't think that it goes anywhere.
Yeah. You know? Well, it's also sad,
right? It's like, it's deeply sad. I mean,
I see this with this crew going after
me all the time and I just ignore it.
But it's like the idea that you're
waking up in the morning and go into,
where did Ruben say today so I can
get some clicks? It's like, man,
there's so many things going on
in the world that pathetic. Yeah.
And it's like I'm not perfect and I've
made mistakes in this very room on this
show, but it's like if you're waking up
going, this is the guy we got to go after.
I, I see more value than it says about me.
It does. And I, and I feel sorry, I just,
I, I feel sorry for their life because
I just, there's nowhere to go from that.
And I would like to use
these opportunities that
I'm getting right now too.
I want to engage people,
but I also want to empower people.
Like I want to empower my people
is much crap as Candice Owens gets.
And Man, she gets the a level
that I couldn't even dream of.
She is a true believer.
She is really out here
trying to empower people.
She is really out here trying
to wake people up. And I um,
I saw a Bernay Brown special, I think
her name is Renee Brown on Netflix.
So she's apparently enormously
huge motivational speaker
but I'd never heard of,
um, so she just got, um,
promoted to me on Netflix.
So I decided to watch a little bit
of, of Bom special. And she said that,
and I think she,
I think this is a doodle Roosevelt quote.
She said that don't worry about critiques
that come from people who are not in
the field,
who are not in the battle,
who are not putting themselves out there
in some way and trying to affect change
in some way.
And now that I've saw,
I've seen that that's how
I try to live my life.
And because you can't take
all of these critiques,
there was a point where you can get 90%
of love from people and we'll follow
because sometimes in the person of, Hey,
you know, I was really doing stand up.
I always remember I could be killing
like 300 people laughing hysterically.
If there's one guy look at his phone,
it's like,
that's the guy I'm looking at that there's
a guy that was asleep in my lecture
last night. Did you call
it out? I did. I said,
I didn't call him up directly, but I was
like giving my speech and I was like,
you know, and, and I think that
everybody needs to have conversations.
Even that guy is funny. He
wake up. He did. He did.
Uh, I'm sorry we didn't
do more of this earlier,
but tell me a little bit just about
your service having nothing to do with,
with all of this stuff
only. And that's, yeah,
just, you know, my service in general,
I think that when I look
back at the military service,
what I regret is that,
you know,
people come up to you when
you're a veteran and they
thank you for your service.
And like people call me a hero
and all that other stuff in it.
I'm always uneasy by that because I
didn't do anything particularly heroic.
I was a young kid.
Um,
just just trying to make it from
one day to the next. I mean,
I was doing things that I believed in,
but when I look at some of these kids
that are serving right now and they're the
same age, I was, you
know, 1920, 21 years old,
it's so much for a young
person to take on. But for me,
when I look back at it
and it just, it, you know,
I lost weight and it gave me
discipline and it gave me kind of that,
that strong male influence
that was missing in my life.
And when I talk about my service,
it's not so much the day to day of what
I did because it was really, you know,
I did one tour in Kuwait, I did one
tour in Iraq right after the invasion.
Um, you connect those dots, you
can get to that age question. Yeah,
yeah. [inaudible] it, yeah.
Connect the dots. It's okay.
Um, but when I look back
to that, we were just,
I was just trying to do the best that I
could and everybody that I served with,
we were just trying to do our best and I,
the people that are serving the military,
they are heroes from like, you know,
from the guy who captured a Sama Bin,
Ladin indies,
these great men that you see these
books from and all that stuff.
But just the people that
give up three, four, five,
sometimes 20 and 25 years of their
life to be of service in some way.
Like there is a very
heroic element to that.
And I think that with me and my service,
I talk about it a lot and I talk about
loving America because it has given me so
much.
Just that service has just put me onto
a path that just sitting here with you
right now and coming back from being
with Candice and going to events in the
White House, like what? What were
black kid from Akron, Ohio could,
could see that vision for himself in
the military put me on the path to doing
all of these things,
so I don't look at myself as heroic,
but I look at all the people that
are serving now as as heroic.
It's to me it's very strange. I feel like
I'm not giving you an answer, but no, no.
It's very hard to reconcile who I am now
with who I was then and to see that as
anything other than a scared
kid doing the best he could,
if that makes sense. It does make sense
and that feels like a nice ending. Yeah.
How do you feel about that?
I think that's a great ending.
I don't know what I'm doing later,
but there would be something if we just
showed up at the Abbey in West Holly.
Oh my God. Are you, can we find some
other band that deplorable? Oh my God,
we should, we should make
it happen. We should,
we should make the could the conservative
gay meetup or something like that.
We should make it happen.
Classical liberal. Oh, that's
right. Classical liberal.
Come on for more on Rob.
Follow him on Twitter at Rob Smith online.